[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur arrivés après avoir joué à
feucherolles dans le club de ma ville
j'ai fait quatre cinq années un peu
d'écoles de foot et jusqu'à u16 à peu
près après je suis parti dans d'autres
clubs de région parisienne et voilà ça
ça va pas mettre au marché j'ai pas pu
aller au niveau que je souhaitais du
coup je suis revenue là un senior en
nationale 3 et là c'est ma quatrième
année on a fait la montée en national d
ela on aspire à aller le plus haut
possible
ce serait un peu moins avancés mais je
sais que c'est toujours ça a toujours
été un club cas de bonnes
infrastructures pour les jeunes qui met
les moyens qui est très bien encadrés
par des bonnes personnes et là avec
l'arrivée des actionnaires qui nous
aident pour essayer de franchir un cap
c'est c'est quelque chose de bien pour
le club et ça me fait plaisir de voir un
club des yvelines qui arrive à ce niveau
là
honnêtement je reste concentré sur sur
sur ce que j'ai à faire sur le terrain
tout ce qui est média honnêtement c'est
un plaisir de voir que les gens parlent
de moi et reconnaisse le travail mme
travailler moi après ça ça me touche ça
me fait plaisir mais je suis pas là à
m'enflammer ou quoi que ce soit je reste
focus sur le terrain je sais ce que j'ai
à faire j'ai des ambitions et je vais
tout faire pour les attend alors quelles
sont vos joueurs préférés
avec nos chouchous mike brant j'ai signé
d un petit peu rigoler chebah dans le
vestiaire sur cette vidéo
on avait regardé gestion juste avant un
match de championnat on était tous
ensemble et on a bien rigolé il sent
fort
si nous sinon on n'y croit pas acquis
qui va y croire pour nous quand vous
regardez les pronostics ou ce que disent
les gens forcément on part perdant parce
qu'on est on joue là bas je vous fasse
un très gros ligue 1 mais nous on est
convaincu que on a notre notre pièce à
jouer et qui on a le niveau pour essayer
de les embêter un peu et d'aller
accrocher quelque chose
[Applaudissements]